(upbeat music)
- I am Johnathan Grahm
and I am the chocolatier
and owner of Compartes Chocolate
and I'm gonna be your expert
for valentines chocolate.
I've probably never eaten
chocolate like this before
so you're gonna be on
an adventure with me.
It certainly didn't smell chocolaty.
It smelled sugary.
You know what else, I hate not knowing.
This tastes like the
candy that you would get
when you were a little kid.
It's fun, it's candy.
It's in a heart shaped box.
We've gone a lot bigger as you
can see just from the plate.
No guide.
I'll say it does look nice that there's
white chocolate, milk
chocolate, dark chocolate.
If you don't know what the person likes
you've got a good variety box in here.
This is better than the previous ones.
I might even actually just taste another.
I don't know what that one is
but it's got some crunch to it.
There was a snap on the chocolate.
If you want chocolate you should
actually go for chocolate.
Again, dark chocolate, high cocoa content.
I think this would be a good gift
to give if you were 21,
but if you're 30 you need
to step up your game.
The most happy this makes
me is that there is a guide
because that means at
least I can kind of see
what I want to go with
instead of mystery chocolate.
One that says Honey Buttery Caramel.
No snap on this chocolate.
It's not honey, it's not buttery.
This type of caramel and this type
of consistency means preservatives.
That really makes me depressed
because all the other boxes,
I didn't know what I was getting
and now the one that I really
wanted is such a letdown.
The caramel consistency is really nice.
It's a nice deep caramel color.
The milk chocolate shell is so thick.
They've lathered on so much milk chocolate
that it overpowers the caramel.
If you're just gonna give
your valentine milk chocolate,
go buy a milk chocolate bar.
The milk chocolate quality
of this product is the best
of the quality that we've tried.
I like the butteriness and consistency
on the inside of this.
This is more of a true truffle cause
it has a creamy chocolate center.
This one's okay, it's not great.
But it's much more inline with my taste
and higher end chocolate than
what we've been tasting previously.
Again, a lot of the pieces we saw
before are very generic looking.
This is prettier.
Not bad.
It had the snap.
I don't know if you heard it.
It's really plain and
milk chocolate and simple
but it's okay.
I'm not mad at it.
If you can't afford a
really big box of chocolate,
get a smaller box that's good.
I think that when you're
giving a valentines gift,
it needs to be unique.
You have one day a year to show yourself.
You could screw up the
chocolate and be sent home.
What about making something at home.
You could just buy
chocolate and melt it down
and get some strawberries and dip them
and that's so much more
unique and special.
I just love the candle and
champagne set up. (laughs)
You're gonna get chocolate,
candles, champagne.
We're just missing the flowers.
But you know flowers die
and chocolate lives forever
or until you eat it.